l'armée ukrainienne en reconnaissance
dans un village bombardé tout près de la
ligne de fond
des tirs d'armes automatiques au loin et
des civils qui ont choisi de rester
malgré les tirs d'obus le premier impact
est tombé à 50 mètres de cet immeuble
j'ai vu dans le ciel une boule de feu
grosse comme ça elle est tombée comme
une météorite
j'ai été poussé par le souffle devant
l'immeuble des observateurs ukrainiens
il collabore avec l'eau et c'est eux cet
organisme international qui recense les
violations du cessez le feu
de quelle direction venait les
projectiles il essaie de répondre à
cette question
mais ne sont pas autorisés à nous parler
plus loin ce militaire nous montre l'un
des points d'impact d'obus il affirme
que les responsables ce sont les
séparatistes pro-russes soutenu par
moscou
je ne peux pas dire exactement d'où ça
vient pour des raisons de sécurité mais
pour moi c'est clair cela vient de l'est
sur la ligne de front de l'autre côté ce
sont les séparatistes pro-russes ici ce
sont les ukrainiens
des soldats que l'on ne voit jamais
faire usage de leurs armes l'armée
ukrainienne communique sur des sommes
aux aguets mais jamais à l'offensive
tous bien sûr suivent les négociations
diplomatiques en
je ne crois pas que
c'est un homme qui n'acceptera pas de
reculer j'ai peut-être tort mais il ne
tient pas ses promesses
toujours sur la ligne de front un point
de passage entre les deux territoires
ennemis ces civils arrivent de la
république séparatiste pro russe des
femmes souvent bouleversé retrouvons des
proches vivant en ukraine
la tension est en fait la même pour tous
ces civils qu'ils vivent d'un côté ou de
l'autre
je ne peux pas parler c'est trop dur
tout ça
sur cette ligne de front longue de 427
km les avis sont partagés certains
soldats sont convaincus que la paix est
encore possible d'autres disent que la
guerre est inévitable
une certitude d'un côté comme de l'autre
on se rejette la responsabilité des
violations du cessez le feu